mona bonjour alors déjà plus d'un mois
plus in est en grève quel est l'objectif
de ce nouveau rassemblement pour les
salariés l'objectif est simplement que
cette saisine ne ferme pas il existe a
choisi depuis plus de 70 ans et près de
260 salariés sont en danger
ils viennent d'arriver devant le site
regarder c'est ce site ici sur les
images de nicolas brun clair qui existe
depuis des années et que les salariés ne
veulent pas voir fermé puisqu'il
contribue au rayonnement de la ville de
choisy le roi dans le val demain
regardez ici les manifestants commencent
à arriver cette mobilisation elle a
commencé à aux alentours de 14 heures
dans une très bonne ambiance on a pu
voir beaucoup de ferveur beaucoup de
solidarité de la part des salariés ici
qui ne veulent pas que cette usine soit
transféré à flins dans les yvelines on a
pu leur parler ils parlent de cette
usine comme une deuxième famille
ecoutez-le
pour un jeune diplômé comme moi c'est un
environnement impeccable agréable ce
propos c est donc une décision brutale
comme ça ça fait mal je peux vous dire
que ça fait mal ce qui me dérange le
plus de parties relativité qui part à
flins c'est plutôt pour les autres parce
que c'est des gens qui sont contents car
en tant qu'arrière et ils ont vécu a
choisi doivent aller faire deux heures
de route ou trois heures femmes c'est
pas admissible là en gros on a eu les
grandes lignes de l'annonce
la prochaine étape ce sera le 16 juin et
l attente pour la plupart des salariés
les très dur parce qu'on sait pas où est
ce qu'on va être comment comment ce sera
le transfert sera aménagé voilà on n'a
aucune idée
plusieurs centaines de manifestants de
salariés sont ont répondu présent à
l'appel de syndicalisme est également
d'élus et de verre qui sont venus
soutenir cette mobilisation et qui ne
veulent pas est la fermeture de renault
à choisy-le-roi je vous propose
également de les écouter et se met un
peu le doigt dans l'oeil de croire que
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des salariés vont
aller à 70 kilomètres d'ici vous savez
c'est une ineptie
on essaie de travailler fortement sur le
fait que le temps de déplacement entre
le lieu de travail et le lieu
d'habitation soit réduit en plus on est
sur une usine vertueuse qui travaillent
sur l'économie circulaire on connaît les
expertises des salariés et de leur
formation etc
donc il faut valoriser faut valoriser
ceux du donc ce lieu doit rester un lieu
productif un lieu économique fort pour
le bassin d'emploi de saint amour
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour
aussi sanofi le groupe parisien val de
marne avec justement retirer les pages
va demander journalisme des salariés des
femmes et des hommes qui l'ont tant
qu'élu c'est la moindre des choses de
présent et c'est le sud iran
en fait combien c'est important pour moi
d'être à ce rassemblement pour une
raison
d'abord pour défendre
l'industrie française son implantation
sur le territoire et puis aussi parce
que je suis convaincu on ne peut pas
d'une main donné des milliards à une
autre fils donc je rappelle que les
tabous et au cap total et ne pas lui
imposer
certain nombre de conditions et la
première de
conditions c'est le maintien de
l'activité industrielle sur le
territoire d'une des usines
industrielles
une des dernières usines industrielles
du secteur
donc c'est important de garder ce
potentiel
et puis dans les circonstances actuelles
de recevoir cinq milliards
et puis finalement décidé de réduire les
emplois c'est totalement indécent il
faut savoir que sur les 14 sites à
renault en france choisy-le-roi renault
est un des seuls qui va voir ses portes
se fermer en 2022 et cela fait partie du
plan d'économies de ron antibes
économiser et qui a annoncé la
suppression de 15 me l'envoie dans le
monde entier dont 4600 en france
uniquement pour faire une économie de
2,5 milliards d'euros
merci beaucoup mon amour toutes ces
précisions mot namouh dès lors en direct
de choisy-le-roi dans le val-de-marne